et
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ni
bonsoir à toutes et à tous et bienvenue
dans votre 7,8 week end voici les titres
de ce vendredi 11 juin
jeudi avait lieu la première journée
robotique à versailles-satory l'armée de
terre l'entreprise nexter et le
groupement des industries françaises de
défense et de sécurité terrestre et aéro
terrestres ont présenté des technologies
et robots militaires mais aussi détaillé
le projet vulcain également une première
collecte de sang organisée par le ffs
avait lieu à toussus-le-noble ce
vendredi 11 juin elle inaugurait
l'ouverture de la nouvelle section don
du sang de l'association la maison pour
tous notre invité à ce sujet yves hocher
days responsable de cette nouvelle
section
côté loisirs enfin cette semaine avec
célia agathe son go nous vous
proposerons de découvrir une exposition
au musée du jouet à poissy et nous irons
aussi au nautic parc le parc d'activités
nautiques de bougival
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
l'armée de terre l'entreprise nexter et
le groupement des industries françaises
de défense de sécurité terrestre et aéro
terrestres ont organisé jeudi 10 juin
la première journée robotique à satory
technologies et robots militaires ont
été présentés l'occasion aussi de
détailler le projet vulcain sur les
systèmes automatisés pour le futur de
l'armée de terre le reportage de nicolas
landry et choristes ernt chagnon avoir
des unités robotisée à l'horizon 2040 en
s'appuyant sur des systèmes déjà utilisé
ou en cours de développement
l'objectif du projet vulcain de l'armée
de terre présenté lors de la journée
robotique à satory des systèmes
automatisés au coeur de la collaboration
entre l'armée de terre et les
industriels de la défense
si on veut vraiment progressé faire
progresser la france côté industriel
côté business et nos armées je parle
pour l'armée de terre
il est important qu on coopère on met
toutes en synergie pour demain à voir la
super yachts est opérationnel sur nos
éventuels et ni l'armée terre n'a pas la
capacité de production des matériels et
on n'a pas forcément non plus toute la
matière grise pour réfléchir à ckoi le
sait quoi la conflictuelle enfin les
équipements qu'il nous faut pour
l'accomplir tu alité des années 2040
voilà donc il faut des bureaux d'études
les bureaux d'études ils sont dans les
chais des industriels pour cette journée
17 entreprises ont pu présenter leurs
technologies robotiques et systèmes
autonomes
c'est le cas de shark robotics cette pme
basée à la rochelle développe ses deux
robots avec des fonctions différentes se
développe actuellement sur le secteur
défense et sécurité également avec le
robot barracuda que vous pouvez voir ici
est une mule multi missions pour le
support des forces armées en opex autres
solutions présentées lors de cet
événement avec ce
nous renseignements reconnaissance et
identification les usages de ce système
relié à une station au sol une
technologie développée par thales sur le
site et l'on peut donc ce système de
drones
c'est un système avec une station sol
une liaison de données et 3 vecteur
aérien comme celui ci qui permettent
d'observer de renseigner de désigner
tout au long des opérations des forces
armées de terre sur le drone vous pouvez
retrouver un des éléments les plus
importants qui la boule optronique qui
est une boule gyrostabilisée avec une
voix à jour électronique voit jour haute
définition une caméra infrarouge pour
voir de nuit et aussi à un dessinateur
laser qui permet de désigner pour
expérimenter les systèmes une section
robotique sera créé à l'été 2000 21 au
centre d'entraînement aux actions en
zone urbaine à sissonne dans le
département de l'aisne si le projet et
vulcain a pour ambition de développer
des systèmes robotiques et autonome
ce programme s'inscrit dans le cadre
éthique de l'armée de terre en écoute
à ce propos le général de corps d'armée
hervé guyomard au micro de choristes et
chagnon et nicolas landry le principe
éthique de l'armée de terre mais qui est
le principe éthique du ministère c'est
bien de garder l'homme dans la boucle
avant de délivrer des feux voilà c'est
pas un système autonome qui va à les
neutraliser des ennemis voilà il ya des
compétiteurs dont des possibles ennemis
mais des gens aujourd'hui sur des
théâtres d'opérations qui font déjà ça
voilà aujourd'hui il ya un principe
éthique que nous devons et que nous
respecterons
comme je vous le disais en titre ce
vendredi 11 juin avait lieu la première
collecte de sang à toussus le noble
cette collecte organisée par
l'établissement français du sang
inaugurait la nouvelle section don du
sang nommé 100% tous eu de l'association
la maison pour tous nous nous sommes
rendus sur place avec mélanie poquet
pour rencontrer yves hocher days
responsable de cette nouvelle section
regarder bonjour et y voit le dev manger
hors éléments vous êtes le responsable
de cette nouvelle section don du sang à
la maison pour tous de toussus le noble
alors ici on est
à la salle du plessis à toussus le noble
pour la première collecte de sang
organisée dans ce cadre là avec le ffs
l'établissement français du sang
alors d'abord un rendez vous qui a du
succès vous avez ouvert d'abord 70
créneaux pour cette collecte de sang le
ffs a dû ouvrir 20 autres tout est
complet est ce que vous êtes satisfait
évidemment évidemment c'est une immense
joie pour nous de voir qu'il ya eu un
réel engouement et un réel engouement
des nobel tu sois et des nouvelles this
was les 70 créneaux étaient pris
d'assaut littéralement en une seule
semaine et et grâce à le fs on a pu
solliciter des créneaux supplémentaires
ce qui n'était pas forcément évident sur
un plan logistique mais ça a été rendue
possible
d'ailleurs j'en profite pour souligner
le soutien incroyable de le fs leur
réactivité tout ça a été a été mis en
place vraiment très très rapidement et
le succès est au rendez vous on a 90
créneau confirmé juste de commencer donc
pour le moment pas d'annulation on
espère ne pas en avoir et j'ai des
participants listes d'attentes sur mon
téléphone que qui n'attendent qu'une
chose c'est qu'on leur fasse un petit
coup de fil pour leur dire mais c'est
bon il ya une place tu peux venir quoi
donc un succès vous l'avez dit du une
volonté commune entre le fs la ville et
vous même avec l'association cent pour
sang tous eu voilà que vous avez créés
qu'est ce qui vous a motivé justement
organisé deux premières collectes à vous
investir pour cette cause
alors c'est une démarche assez
personnelle puisque j'ai moi même dû
être transfusé dernièrement à la fois de
sang et de plaquettes à quatre reprises
je souffre d'un cancer et dans le cadre
de cette maladie je reçois plein de
médicaments et
qui me sont administrés et la première
fois où j'étais perfusé transfuser du
sang d'un donneur voilà ça m'a fait
vraiment quelque chose de me dire voilà
on n'est pas sur une molécule issue d'un
laboratoire pharmaceutique on est sur le
don d'un être humain qui a donné de lui
même pour me soigner pour me sauver
et donc voilà c'est tout est parti de là
en me disant je ne peux plus donner de
mon sens aujourd'hui mais je peux donner
de montant et donc voilà c'est la raison
pour laquelle j'ai souhaité solliciter
d'abord le ffs et puis sollicité ensuite
notre mairie qui a été très réactive
réceptive et tout ça s'est mis en place
très facilement et donc vous avez créé
mais aussi cette section don du sang à
la maison pour tous comment ça va se
passer ensuite après cette première
collecte est ce qu'il va y en avoir
d'autres
quel va être son rôle finalement à cette
section don du sang le rôle de la de la
section 100% tous uc2 de fédérer les
collectes enfin de communiquer entre le
l'établissement français du sang et la
mairie tout su nous à titre de bénévole
vient d'organiser à l'ouverture de la
porte de la salle l'accueil des
participants dans la remise des
bouteilles d'eau aux fins de voilà dès
l'aller comment dire les la campagne
d'affichage de boîtage des flyers dans
les boîtes aux lettres des habitants de
tout su et des villages et des villes
des villes voisines
et voilà c'est un travail
pas très sympa qui nous a permis de
travailler en équipe avec les bénévoles
et en donc là on est une équipe de sept
bénévoles ce qui pour le moment est
amplement suffisant on sonde les
donneurs là aujourd'hui à l'arrivée pour
justement solliciter les uns et les
autres pour éventuellement du bénévolat
et voilà c'est c'est à terme vous
aimeriez organiser d'autres couleurs
douces est prévu c'est prévu donc
prochaine date le 16 le 16 septembre
jeudi 16 septembre sur le même créneau
14h 19h ici même
combien de créneau vert alors là on est
sur 90 aujourd'hui voilà alors vais
justement moi j'avais j'avais été un
petit peu moins ambitieux que que
l'établissement français du sang en
disant voilà c'est une deuxième collecte
est ce que l'effet télétravail reprise
du travail en présentiel va encourager
autant les gens à venir un jour de
semaine je ne sais pas est ce qu'on
partirait pas sur 70 créneaux et puis la
direction de la fff a jugé opportun au
contraire de partir directement sur 90
créneau en se disant pas tous eu ça a
marché
on a des besoins on a des besoins
énormes en ce moment et allons-y quoi et
justement pour ses besoins énormes pour
la troisième année consécutive le ffs a
lancé sa campagne nationale prenait le
relais un mois pour tout donner
un appel aux dons du 9 juin au 9 juillet
car la réserve vous l'avez dit sont très
basses surtout à la proche de l'été
c'est une grosse inquiétude pour le ffs
cette collecte
elle s'inscrit quand même dans ce cadre
là aussi puisque c'est depuis le 9 juin
c'est important pour vous vous l'avez
déjà dit mais est ce que c'est vraiment
important pour vous de contribuer à
aider d'autres patients soit dans votre
cas soit dans d'autres cas là et
naturellement c'est voilà c'est un
engagement associatif qui qui qui est
encourageant parce que face à un tel
engouement ne peut qu'être encouragée
tout de suite un petit village on croise
des voisins des amis qui vous disaient
mais c'est génial ce que tu as fait
pourquoi on n'y a pas pensé plus tôt et
et voilà donc c'est vraiment c'est
vraiment super c'est vraiment super on
est on est plus que plus que ravis et
pour répondre à votre question par
rapport à apprenez le relais
on sollicite sur la base du volontariat
aujourd'hui tous les donneurs à être
pris en photo on va leur faire un petit
badge
j'ai donné mon sang a tous eu maintenant
prenez le relais qu'on va diffuser sur
nos réseaux sociaux qu'on va le renvoyer
sur leur adresse email de sorte que eux
mêmes puissent les relayer sur leurs
propres réseaux sociaux voilà c'est
notre petite contribution à cette
opération d'envergure sur laquelle on
veut vraiment participer être acteur
merci yves hocher days de nous avons
reçu ici à la salle du plessis pour
cette première collecte de sang
bonne fin de collecte à vous on souhaite
également que la prochaine collecte soit
réussi et nous regardons tout de suite
le reste de ce qui a fait l'actualité
cette semaine dans les yvelines au micro
de bixente merrien santisteva nous cette
semaine marque la deuxième étape du
déconfinement et du retour à la normale
de la vie des yvelinois depuis mercredi
les restaurants peuvent enfin installer
leurs clients en intérieur et rester
ouverts plus tard jusqu'à 23 heures
d'autres lui ont également pu rouvrir
leurs portes salle de sport cours de
yoga ou encore piscine à l'image des
bassins des clayes-sous-bois qui
accueille de nouveau les nageurs après
huit mois de fermeture
avec l'été qui se prépare certains
établissements peinent à employer les
saisonniers se sont pour certains des
tournées du secteur faute d'ouverture
incertaine et hardy au parc de loisirs
france miniature à elancourt par exemple
certains postes sont encore vacants
de lundi à vendredi la ville de
rambouillet a ouvert un vaxy drive
éphémère à l'hippodrome attentes des
placements et vaccins tout ce qui est
fait en voiture un système rapide et
réitérée dans six semaines pour
permettre à environ 2000 personnes de
recevoir leurs deux injections
le personnel des mairies mobilisés
depuis plusieurs jours pour préparer la
double élection des 20 et 27 juin
prochain entre bonne coordination et
mesures sanitaires l'objectif est
d'accueillir les 1 million 400 mille
événements sécurité dans les bureaux de
vote
enfin du sport le président de la
république a rendu visite à l'équipe de
france de football à clairefontaine ce
jeudi 10 juin
accompagné de son épouse brigitte macron
des présidents de la fédération
française de football et de la fifa
emmanuel macron est venu encourager les
bleus pour l'euro 2020 qui débutera
mardi 15 juin prochain face à
l'allemagne
[Musique]
et après cette semaine bien chargée et
quoi de mieux que de se détendre
comme chaque vendredi célia gars tsongo
vous propose ses idées sorties et
loisirs
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oh
cette semaine nous allons nous
rafraîchir en cette période de beau
temps depuis le 22 mai le nautic parc
est de nouveau ouvert au public de
nombreuses activités loisirs nautiques
sont proposés pour passer un après midi
en famille au bord de la seine le
montage d'arthur big embarquement
immédiat
le nautic parc à bougival a rouvert ses
portes il ya trois semaines
il propose pour les enfants une formule
anniversaire chaque week end
accompagnés de leurs parents les enfants
vont faire une demi-heure de zodiac sur
l'eau ils ont des petites énigmes à
résoudre
ils viennent pendant deux heures une
heure d'activité nautique sur le club
moussaillons et dans les eaux diack
abordé zodiac et puis une heure où ils
peuvent tranquillement goûter échanges
et les gâteaux les cadeaux et des passer
un petit moment sympathique
cet après midi là un anniversaire était
organisée parce qu'on a des affinités
déjà avec l'eau et puis on trouvait que
c'était sympa de faire faire une
activité dans l'eau aux enfants et de
faire découvrir aussi le nautisme
certains enfants qui n'ont pas eu
l'occasion d'en faire jusqu'ici pas sept
ans ces jeunes encore tous les week-ends
de 14 heures à 17 heures des escapades
en zodiac pour les adultes sont aussi
organisé une balade commentée de trente
minutes pour découvrir le berceau des
impressionnistes les réservations sont
souvent complète depuis la réouverture
du parc d'activités nautiques
on avait déjà des gens qui nous a appelé
pour dire à quel moment on peut réserver
à quel moment on leur a donné le top dos
et voilà et avant nous faisions maximum
deux anniversaires par jour il ya une
telle demande qu'on est passé à trois
anniversaires pour les enfants qui ne
souffre leur est pas leurs bougies
il existe le club moussaillons
accessible de 3 à 12 ans cet espace
flottant de 200 m² contient une pêche
aux canards et plus sur l'eau et des
pédalos j'ai fait du trampoline
j'ai bien aimé parce que j'adore ce thé
après j'ai fait les bulles dans l'eau
il fallait tourner je connais cette
année nous avons commencé par la balade
en zodiac
nous avons fait une balade de 30 minutes
et après ma fille et l'a fait de la
trampoline et nous on a profité de ce
coin tranquille pour bord des boissons
fraîches
le nautic parc propose également son
circuit des impressionnistes pour
découvrir les grands noms des peintres
de cette époque une escapade commenté de
deux heures prochaines dates dimanche 13
juin
un bal sera aussi organisé dimanche 20
juin avec buvette actuellement musée du
jouet à poissy l'exposition jardins
d'enfants se présentent des jeux
d'enfants sur la thématique du jardin
des jouets datant du xviiie siècle à nos
jours sont exposés bérengère bourgoin
s'est rendu remise et jeux de société
air biais poupée ou encore jeux de
marelle
la collection est large au musée du
jouet qui présente son exposition jardin
d'enfance se trouve que maintenant après
de confinement n'est pas encore plus on
a encore plus envie de sortir envie de
profiter de la nature donc voilà voir
les jouets du jardin rencontrait tous
ces jeux auxquels on jeu les enfants
d'autrefois et ceux d'aujourd'hui en
lien avec les extérieurs ça un vrai
attrait pour le public
en plus de l'exposition des jouets en
intérieur les jardins du musée sont
aussi accessibles et vont accueillir au
mois de juillet des ateliers
alors le don qu'il ya toutes les joies
qui sont eux évidemment à l'intérieur
des vitrines qu'on ne peut pas toucher
donc c'est toujours un peu frustrant
pour les enfants de voir des choses et
pas pouvoir jouer avec
donc on organise autour de l'exposition
toute une programmation d'animations et
d'ateliers durant lesquelles les enfants
vont découvrir certains de ses jeux et
pouvoir les pratiques et les enfants de
4 à 12 ans pourront participer à ces
ateliers
la visite est possible dès le plus jeune
âge les jeux par le plus grand nombre
on considère qu'à partir de quatre ont
en fait
l'exposition et certains ateliers sont
accessibles pour les enfants et puis on
va dire que ça va pour les ateliers
c'est jusqu'à 12 ans après l'exposition
elles évidemment elle intéresse aussi
tous les adultes jusqu'à tous les âges
est ouverte seulement un mois à cause du
confinement l'exposition est
exceptionnellement prolongé jusqu'à la
fin de l'année pour permettre aux
visiteurs de mieux en profiter
une journée d'hommage sera rendu à elsa
triolet ce samedi 12 juin à la maison à
elsa triolet aragon situé à
saint-arnoult-en-yvelines pour fêter le
cinquantième anniversaire de sa mort de
nombreuses animations seront prévues
guillaume roubaud kwasi bonsoir bonsoir
vous êtes le directeur de la maison elsa
triolet aragon alors normalement
l'hommage aurait dû avoir lieu l'année
dernière mais la pandémie vous en a
empêchés quel est le programme de cette
année alors on sait qu'à ce trio est un
nom très connu mais on connaît moins son
oeuvre et nous pensions qu en oeuvre est
à découvrir alors on a voulu de mettre
en majesté ses mots et donc on ces mots
on va les entendre à travers des
comédiens et des comédiennes qui vont
prêter leur voix au bo de ce trio laisse
et mâcha méril ce sera catherine salviat
de la comédie française
on a voulu y simuler les générations et
seront donc devenu comédien de la maison
de la culture de seine-saint-denis qui
viendront également on entendra
également les modeuses à triolet par
elsa triolet pascal agnès varda avait
fait un film autour d'elle à triolet
dont compromettra en plein air puisque
toute la programmation se déroulera en
plein air il y aura aussi de la musique
un concert classique parce que
rostropovitch était venu jouer sur la
tombe d'aller à triolet et xavier
phillips un de ses disciples à venir
jouer sur la tombe d un trio laid
j'oubliais d'autres aspects parce que on
va peut-être y revenir par la scion aux
idées des conférences seront aussi à
proposer normalement exactement commence
le matin à 10 heures avec des
conférences et l'après midi on a un
programme de lecture de textes à triolet
un débat avec des écrivains autour des
triolets ce temps de communic classique
ce temps de cinéma en plein air à la fin
de la journée
et puis il ya aussi un passage moins
connu c'est que aragon a été chanté bien
sûr mais est un trio l'est aussi en
l'occurrence par vannes moreau
s'appelait les chansons de clarisse et
là il se trouve que
vous proposera avec jacques verdier et
bien une nouvelle version nouvelle
interprétation de ses chansons de
clarisse et pillards également pour
terminer dès comment dire des
performances artistiques qui auront lieu
toute la journée avec petite
poissonnerie dans mes sacs et à midi on
aura le plaisir d'inaugurer avec la
poste
un timbre un timbre elsa triolet qui
sera inaugurée samedi et qui sera
disponible dans tous les bureaux de vote
de postes or donc ce que c'est moi à
partir d'aujourd'hui
oui c'est vraiment des animations tout
au long de la journée 1
mais finalement le but de l'événement
c'est de faire connaître lé trio laisser
ça exactement parce que à triolet ça
reste un nom connu mais on la connaît
comme la muse d'aragon en réalité
derrière ce nom il y à la première femme
prix goncourt il y à une femme qui est à
la tête d'une oeuvre en deux langues une
en russe non français il ya la
traductrice aussi bien darabont que de
voyage au bout de la nuit
c'est elle qui dans du russe vers le
français est traduite ou tchekhov
voilà c'est une grande femme de lettres
et il était temps je crois de de la
mettre sous la lumière c'est c'est en
1970 1,15 à triolet est décédé on pourra
plaire aux téléspectateurs
cette journée donc particulière puisque
l'on fête cet anniversaire funeste mais
finalement la maison elsa triolet
on peut dire qu'elle veut rend hommage
tous les jours finalement oui c'est vrai
on essaie de s'inscrire dans ses pas
avec notamment toute la programmation
artistique qu'on a parce que hazard en
fin de lettre
et sensible toute sa vie à aux enjeux
plastique et ainsi on a des expositions
qu'on propose toute l'année
en ce moment on a une grande exposition
de pierre buraglio et de co2 buraglio
qui s'appelle juin 1re d et qui sera
visible jusqu'à jusqu'à la rendre
et justement est ce qu'on pourra voir
ces expositions
lors de cette journée du 12 juin oui les
expositions sont accessibles tout se
fait sur réservation dans le cadre des
du protocole sanitaire bien sûr afin de
respecter les jauges même que les
visites qui ont repris avec le 9 juin
mais dans le cadre de josé donc sur
réservation et puis on a tout d'une
programmation en plein air que nous
avons tous les ans et qui reprend cette
année on aura ainsi début juillet une
programmation important de plus familial
qui s'appelle jardins en fête et qui
mêle des spectacles en plein air et des
jeux autour d'eux des plaisirs du jardin
et est ce que d'autres événements aussi
seront à prévoir
oui donc éthique l'année la maison elsa
triolet aragon et maintenant que comme
on dit est grande ouverte
voilà donc on continue nos activités de
visite de la maison du couple
d'écrivains aragon et elsa triolet puis
tous ces volets donc d'initiative
les expositions puis haricots de gravier
ou jusqu'à la rentrée jardin en fait
début juillet et puis d'autres comme on
dirait puis tous les jours donc la
maison des tribus arabes on est taxé au
public à partir de 14 heures et
l'hommage c'est donc samedi 12 de 10h à
22h très bien et bien c'est noté merci
beaucoup
guillaume rococo ainsi d'avoir été notre
invité merci
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et pour finir cette page loisirs je vous
propose deux idées de sorties pour ce
week end le centre port royal à saint
lambert des bois accueille la deuxième
édition du salon art et bien-être ce
week end
70 exposants sont attendus sophrologue
réflexologue ou encore hypnothérapeute
se mêleront aux artistes présents comme
des peintres des photographes ou
sculpteurs des conférences et ateliers
seront aussi organisées tout au long du
week end
montigny le bretonneux salim samedi 12
juin pour fêter la réouverture des bars
et restaurants de nombreuses animations
seront proposées durant cette journée de
10h à 13h une déambulation avec une
mascotte et un jongleur aura lieu sur le
marché de la place etienne marcel
l'après-midi un mime et une
caricaturiste viendront animer le centre
commercial de la marque hayon de 15h à
19h et l'émission continue avec eléonore
pour parler de l'actualité
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
pour refermer ce 7,8 week-end comme
chaque semaine votre rendez-vous en
partenariat avec les surligneurs on
écoute vincent cours à une fondateur des
surligneurs et docteur en droit à
l'université versailles saint quentin le
danemark adopté une loi il ya quelques
jours qu'ils organisent une sous
traitance de la prise en charge des
demandeurs d'asile il s'agit ni plus ni
moins que d'envoyer des demandeurs
d'asile dans des pays de transit par
exemple rwanda où leur demande serait
étudiée
outre que cette politique pourrait être
coûteuse et contraire à plusieurs
obligations internationales du danemark
par exemple le principe selon lequel on
ne refoule pas un demandeur d'asile de
son territoire ou encore la règle qui
interdit toute expulsion collective d'un
état en référence évidente ici aux
déportations des juifs pendant la
seconde guerre mondiale et la question
que pose cette loi danoise un état
membre de l'union européenne
et bien c'est de savoir si la france
pourrait faire de même et n'en déplaise
à ceux qui sur l'échiquier politique
site laden marque en exemple il ya une
différence de taille entre nos deux pays
lors de l'adoption du traité de
maastricht en 1992
le danemark a négocié de ne pas être lié
par les règles européennes sur l'asile
la france ne bénéficie pas de cette
opt-out et doit donc appliquer les
directives européennes qui imposent
d'accueillir les réfugiés
quoi de plus cohérent la france a elle
même votées en faveur de ces directives
on pourrait donc dire dans l'union
européenne 1 2 et à deux ambiances mais
enfin pas tout à fait car le rwanda a
publié un communiqué cette semaine pour
dire notamment son opposition à ce
système qu'il n'appliquera pas et de
toute façon à ce jour aucun pays
notamment en afrique n'a accepté la
proposition du danemark d'accueillir ces
demandeurs d'asile alors la loi danoise
expression de sa souveraineté sur ses
frontières ou gesticulation politique
c'est déjà la fin de votre 7,8 week end
merci de l'avoir suivi on se retrouve la
semaine prochaine je vous souhaite une
excellente soirée et un très bon week
end
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]